hey everybody what's going on it's bobby
here and we're back talking about
something a little bit different here at
geek culture i mean normally we talk
about consumer electronics collectibles
camera gear
but
zacky and i are avid motorcyclists we
love our bikes and
we have in our hands with us today the
first high performance electric
motorcycle in singapore from energica
the eva esse esc nove or nine plus
in the flesh
let's talk about it
all wired up baby
wired up nowhere to go
[Music]
ah
so before we get into these i do want to
let you know that we're not paid or
sponsor for this we've had the bike for
about
two and a half days it goes back later
on this evening so this is gonna be more
of a first impressions and it's gonna be
more about that transition from a
petrol-based motorcycle
to an electric motorcycle what is that
like what are the pros what are the cons
what are the things you need to know
that's we're going to cover in this kind
of hands-on first impressions video of
this
we will talk a little about the specs of
the course the ava ssn9 because the
specs are essential but we're not going
to go too detailed into it because they
have a website with all that information
anyway let's talk about
the design of this first and foremost
this is they're calling it the kind of
the classic motorcycle vibe it does give
me a little bit of that ducati monster
feel to it
it is more of a classic stance more of a
slight upright a little bit lean forward
look to it but you're going to see the
fairings a little bit more sporty a
little bit more futuristic more modern
then you go look to the front of it then
you've got this classic headlight to it
this round circular headlight which kind
of blends old and new to it now this
comes in a variety of colors with the
sas9 you have a blue tank a black tank
or a yellow tank we opted for the black
tank here that's all they currently have
available um there is no red option if
you want to go for red it's the rebellio
or the ergo which are beautiful bikes
more sporty in their design but that's
something to take note of but as we move
to the back you're going to see more in
time in tune with that classic design is
this dark brown um i would say
leatherette or leather seat on this so
it sort of ties in with the gray and the
black gives it a nice classic look some
blue accents around the bike as well
that's to sort of give you that uh that
electric look to it
and then we see you have the sword this
chalice frame here very reminiscent of
course of the ducati monster but as we
see we got the fairings here that gives
it that sport essence to the bike the
mirrors on this are standard of course
personally i would probably offer
something a little bit more lower
profile but they are very visible very
easy to see angular and design
the levers of course all beautifully
made everything is well made on this we
have marzoki uh fun forks on this we've
got to buy tubo rear shock on this on
the back of it we got pirelli uh tires
brembo brakes on the front and back this
is a very high spec out machine so you
are pretty much decked out now in terms
of power you can max this out around 86
kilowatts 80 sustained thereabouts
that's around 100 and 1209 horsepower so
it's not going to be a blazing fast bike
by numbers
but that all changes once you twist the
throttle on this now the top speed on
this is around 200 kilometers per hour
here and that's plenty for most highways
i mean is it gonna compete with leader
bikes no zero to 100 in this
is around three seconds so i guess
depends how you spec it out if you get
the rs variant you can go even faster so
this is a very fast bike and i'll talk
about the performance later on in terms
of how it drives and the throttle the
response all that in just a bit
but
in terms of
the design the look of it it's a very
beautiful looking bike as a matter of
fact i put this up on my instagram
stories and i had a lot of people
commenting on this bike more so than
most of the bikes i put up on there i
would say my speed master comes in first
because it's customized
but this is a very close second
everything that anergic has done to this
is really beautiful in terms of the
display where you see all your
information on the bike it's very
eligible very easy to read it changes
from white in daylight to black at night
time so no issues at all with that could
it be a little bit larger perhaps
there's a big border around it but i'm
not going to fault them for that maybe
that'll come in the near future to
charge this bike it's all underneath the
seat of this now you have two chargers
you have a dc and an ac dc for fast
charging acs for the long term charging
fast charging will get you to a max of
80 on this motorcycle and that will
pretty much cover you for a good portion
of the day or a few days there abouts
because you know energy is touting
around 400 plus kilometers of uh battery
usage in this and this new 21.5 kilowatt
battery that they have in this it's
lighter than the 13.4 and it's got more
power into it so it does bring down the
weight savings on this bike just a bit
but it also depends on how you ride this
motorcycle there are four settings on
this motorcycle in terms of um how you
wanna ride eco
urban rain or sport and of course you
can adjust the regenerative engine
braking as well from eco which is
basically none too high which is really
intense uh so we'll talk a little bit
more about that through the riding
experience as well the one thing missing
that kind of gives it it's
yeah as you can see the cojones the
machoness of a motorcycle is the exhaust
there is none there you get used to it
i mean that's part of the electric
experience but i think the overall
design of the bike really is done so
well in the front mid part of it that
you're not going to miss it too much but
i don't know maybe in the future with
electric motorcycles and put some sort
of faux exhaust on the back with maybe a
speaker in there to give it more of a
louder sound we'll talk about that as
well in the writing experience of this
because the sound on this is very unique
anyway with that let's get on the road
and let's
put this bike through its paces
put this in reverse
tell your reverse is a godsend on this
bike
not that it's that heavy but it does
make a difference
especially
when you need to back up or
you're on a hill or
you're on slippery ground it makes a big
difference
37 charge
yeah we're going to charge up later on
today for this one
all right
off we go
this is gonna be fun
fun day hopefully the weather holds
if it doesn't and when we're
we're pretty much screwed
but oh we'll do what we can
i wish i had a clutch you know going to
do turns and
slow maneuvering
definitely takes some adjustment
all right
this
see this is one of the cool things about
this bike actually is the fact there is
no clutch so
you know if you're sitting here waiting
at a traffic light
or
just want to chill there's no engine
heat there's nothing coming from the
tank at all you feel a slight vibration
um and that's just i guess the the
battery but it's relatively very
quiet and very comfortable
the visor's down
audio's going to change a little bit on
that but
here we go
but as you can tell it's a very quiet
bike i mean it does have this whining
sound it does sound a little bit like
the uh
the dark knight tumbler
obviously smaller of course but it has
that uh
that sound to it that kind of that
winding
sound now i'm not too sure if this is
going to be a problem you know obviously
when you get into heavier traffic
situations because
you know
a lot of countries are trying to reduce
the sound from exhaust pipes but
you know loud noise does save lives to
some extent of course you don't want
something obnoxious but you want
something that other drivers can hear
you especially now with uh
everybody with all this you know android
auto and apple carplay and all that
stuff that they're constantly having
multimedia in their cars and they're
talking on the phone or listening to
spotify or
you know apple music or whatever you
know music platform they used to they're
not going to hear a lot of things around
them
so this bike
is going to be
virtually silent for a lot of those
those drivers so
it's going to be up to us as motorcycles
to be much more aware
and to uh
yeah just be
mindful on the road
and obviously lane splitting like what
that guy is doing right there
might not be something you want to do
with this bike especially because we'll
example for here in singapore you know
drivers do like to change lanes very
suddenly because of our roads and just
because of the driving styles here and
that could cause some issues
because they can't hear you
now of course there's enough power in
this to get out of situations especially
in sports mode but it is something to
take note of uh especially on that
but yeah it's very quiet very chill i
mean the nice thing about this here in
singapore obviously is that
we
you know it's a very hot and humid
climate i would say if you're in
fahrenheit around 85 90 degrees
thereabouts
year-round um sometimes more rain than
others but the humidity is also very
high
so when you're on certain motorcycles
you know that heat that comes from the
engine
you know where the pipes uh depending on
where the pipes are located at it can be
really
it can be very bothersome especially
when you're in urban situations like
this
and the nice thing about this uh eva is
you feel nothing
feels very very comfortable
let's just wind this up a little bit
you know the one thing about this bike
is it's really hard to describe without
actually riding it i'll try my best but
the acceleration is fantastic there is
no i mean the power band on this it just
goes straight up
you turn it it goes
um
that's a good thing but also if you are
new to riding and you think this is
going to be some like you know uh
pmd kind of uh
vehicle that's gonna be nice and easy to
ride around you know
i maybe would say
think twice there's a lot of power
underneath underneath this now of course
you can adjust it you have four
different modes on here let's just go
through those right now we have eco
urban rain sport and which you see abs
on or off and then you have off low
medium high that's for your engine
braking for the regen braking on that
i set it to medium because that seems to
be the um
the area that i like the best i've heard
people like second or third i tried the
highest and it's just too much engine
breaking uh for my personal uh
preference but to each their own this is
one thing you can try and test out on
this bike
uh you know is the various different
modes so usually i'll go in urban but
i've been trying sport for the last you
know day and a half because i only have
this bike for three days so or two and a
half days they're about so it's a little
bit um
you know
you need to live with this bike a little
bit more to understand how it maneuvers
and you know what settings to really
dial in on this and i think if you
become an owner of a bike like this
you're really going to have fun you know
fine tuning it to your liking
for me personally urban is a great
option
still have your torque yourself some
power but it's not gonna it's not like
sport where it can just really
you know
twist it out the model and it goes right
you get some power for sure
but it uh
it's a little bit more
you know easier to ride
now as you can see here i'm not even
using the brake i'm just using the
engine braking i basically just turn the
throttle off and the engine braking
takes over and slows down the bike which
is nice now that's something i would
normally do with a collection gears is i
would downshift and that sort of
replaces it to some extent
but
i think that's going to be the hardest
part for a lot of people out there is
getting used to the fact there is no
clutch and there is no gears and because
the way i was taught to ride a
motorcycle is to really use the clutch
clutch control to really maneuver slow
maneuvers you know things like that
whereas with this bike you're really
reliant on the throttle and
on your rear brake and front brake now i
probably wouldn't use the front brake
that much on this bike because a it's
heavy and b is very strong where you're
going to use the rear brake and of
course the engine braking
a lot more
than you might on a normal motorcycle
because you don't have a clutch so um
something to keep in mind it's just a
learning curve it's uh
i'm still not there yet to be honest
with you it's been you know as i said
about a couple days with this bike about
a day and a half you know sports mode
but a couple days with it and it's still
a lot to learn and to
readjust
you know so i think for a lot of riders
out there who want to go into these
electric motorcycles that's something to
take note of is that there will be that
uh adjustment period and at first it
might be frustrating and you might be
like no i don't want to do this forget
i'll just go back to the standard way of
doing it but you know just like when you
first got your motorcycle you know you
got to learn it you have to spend some
time with it
and uh but just don't hit that front
brake especially on slow maneuvers
because this is a heavy bike
it's not it looks light but it's not
and that's why there is a reverse and
slow moving forward option on this now
here's where it gets tricky um you
turned on this bike and it's going to
take some adjustment because usually i
would use clutch control you know twist
the throttle clutch control you know use
my counterbalance and just go go around
a turn but because we don't have that
clutch control here you're reliant on
the throttle the brake and your
counterbalance so you're missing that
one thing for me at least that
makes me it it's a little bit
challenging to be frank with you uh
u-turns i have not gotten the hang of on
this bike yet i just probably take me a
week or so then i'd be fine with it but
uh you know what i mean it's these are
the small things that you're going to
realize when you drive this but
these are the small things you're going
to realize when you ride this bike
around is that
yes there are going to be situations
like that where you're going to be like
oh it doesn't turn as well or what's
going on here
you're just used to it i mean also case
in point when you're on the highway
and you want to lean into a turn
this bike is a little bit harder to lean
into a turn than let's say a standard
motorcycle um it's not so flickable i
mean it looks like it would be but it's
really not i mean you really got to put
some weight in there into it and uh it's
not a deal breakers just something to
keep note of
see i'm just taking my time on the
u-turn here
it's almost like a new rider but you
know
it's not my bike i don't want to drop it
it has to be returned later on and uh
yeah
so we're going for a little bit of a
bike wash right here
hopefully they say it's okay
[Music]
all right
and the nice thing is if i just take my
hand off the throttle it's quiet i put
the kickstand down
it uh
sort of
pseudo turns off the bike i mean you
still see the electronics but it's
pretty much off
good
hey let's take a look walk around with
it right now it looks it's a really nice
looking bike you know um the rebelle and
of course
the top of the line range is gonna your
goal is gonna look really badass but
this is a bike that's growing on me
design wise i think it's just maybe the
mirrors i would change
perhaps the bars i don't know i mean
jeff that's just me it feels like this
bike needs red but that's where the
rebellion the ergo comes into play
because you can get that red color but
yeah this is uh
pretty interesting anyway let them wash
the bike and uh get back on the road in
just a bit
yeah one of the things about uh riding a
singapore course now we are
a little behind other countries when it
comes to electric vehicles i mean we
have more electric cars here on the road
a lot of our taxis are hybrids but fully
electric is uh still
in its infancy here and we are getting
better but of course this is the first
high performance electric motorcycle on
the roads i think it's the only the
first electric motorcycle on the roads
here to be honest with you i mean we
have a local company making one but
i don't know if people are buying them
yet or if it's still in pre-production
i'm not too sure
but uh this one is out
this one is on the roads
took a few months to get it uh approved
but it is approved and
ready
to be bought now
here's the interesting thing about
buying bikes here in singapore which um
you know i might talk more about later
on this video but anyway it's the price
point because we have a lot of extra
taxes especially when it comes to you
know higher cc bikes and the larger
bikes out there and of course
uh
this is an 80 kilowatt per hour or
something like that uh bike so this is
quite this is considered a class two
here we have three classes of motorcycle
licenses you can get
to uh two b two a and two
but i think when you get to something
like this situation with an electric
motorcycle i don't know how you can have
three classes because
these things can be dialed in to be
whatever you want it to be like case in
point i uh i set this to eco mode my max
speed is 90 kilometers per hour right
and the torque is
really low so that's going to be great
for a novice rider to get used to this
and that's something that a you know a
beginner writer would use versus sport
mode which would be much you know for
the more seasoned writer
uh so
i'm not too sure how singapore is going
to go about that
i think that those uh that three-stage
licensing might have to uh
have another re-look at it because of
the whole electric uh
situation and also how you ride a bike
good stuff really really
i'm really enjoying the ride on this
thing though that's the one thing i can
say about this is that
it does make riding a motorcycle easier
in that regard especially when you're
just doing this kind of traffic it's
very easy quick pick up uh doesn't get
out from under you i mean you've just
got to really understand that this
throttle is sensitive and so just a
slight turn
can make a big difference now this car
right here is moving over here obviously
probably couldn't hear me but it's okay
i saw him with the light so that's
something that you're going to notice
with this bike is you're going to be
more aware with these things because
there's less to do on a motorcycle so
that could be a positive in that regard
but
you know maybe they'll put some speaker
systems on these bikes as they get uh
more matured and a little bit louder
exhaust or maybe there's a button you
can press to just get a little louder
sound
but i have to say there's a very good
horn system on this bike case in point
it's pretty loud right so if there is
somebody that's getting around you and
you're a little bit worried
honk that horn a bit you're gonna be
good
now in terms of the suspension on the
bike we've got the mozoki front end on
it the by tubo rear shocks and i mean
these are high performance parts
but the one thing i'm going to notice is
that this needs to be adjusted a little
bit now it is a demo bike and i'm sure
that people have played around with the
suspension based on their weight
and their preference but for me
it's a little bit jumpy on the road a
little bit more than i'm used to and i
know it's a sport suspension and all
it's going to be quite sensitive but
you know when you're on the highways or
you know just any bump on the road you
really do feel it so it says i mean it's
nothing to do with the bike this is just
more the setting but something to take
note of with uh any motorcycle you get
is obviously adjust the suspension to
your weight to your liking um just don't
take it off the lot without doing any of
that stuff because it can make or break
a riding experience on a motorcycle
so when you're looking at the uh the
power gauge trigger i got about 25 left
so i'm going to get this charged at a
shell station now here in singapore we
can obviously do it through a variety of
different locations uh shell is quite
near me
and i went there the other day to do it
and it takes about uh 12 to 15 minutes
to get this up to about 80 percent and
it's quite cost effective
okay so now we're going to go to uh
shell right here because we can actually
charge the bike fast charging with the
bike here
so they have one port hopefully there is
not a car there
uh i was just here the other day and it
was the first time there saw an electric
motorcycle being charged here so they
were a little bit uh
a little bit impressed by
seeing this to say the least
but uh yeah
we're gonna plug in and get ready
all right 22 remaining
turn off and here we go
so just to kind of walk you through this
real quick here just in case we can't
film i'll use it with the the camera on
the helmet just to walk you through how
you can actually access the charging
ports underneath the seat here
and use the key right here
normally this would be storage and you
can put like you know
put a little bit of storage there but
pop that up now you have two ports here
of your ac and then you have your dc
right here and this is going to uh
you know this is where the fast charging
is this is the slow charging so if you
have a charger at home you'll be using
this um but here for this purpose we're
going to be using the dc for fast
charging
uh so yeah
this is all really done with the app
they call it the ccs here
um that's the fast charging one and then
type two is the older one so
okay
let me get my phone out okay i got 21 of
my balance here we're gonna go to charge
scan qr code
that's it
we're gonna go
ccs type two
50 kilowatts charger on this so this is
fast charging
so we're going to plug this in
and then
we start
charging
on the app now i'm just going to verify
go through the process here you're going
to need your smartphone for this at
shell at least
preparing to charge is going to
communicate so the bike is saying dc
fast charging initialization right there
give it a minute or two
and we're charging
we are charging
charging has started here as you can see
on my phone
and it's gonna say it's about uh
it's counting down
about 24 minutes on this one okay to
about 80 80 charge so
zaki's filming me right now what's up
zacky
what's up so
we're gonna hang out here grab a
sandwich at shell
and yeah wait for this to charge and as
you can tell what's really cool right
here is you can see that this is going
to get giving you the level of your
charge so with this pull setting so
we're right here and then it's just
showing you that charge right there now
this is cool because you can actually
customize this graphic by different
pulsating uh modes on it and that's just
return on of course when you're charging
it's going to keep it as is but it's
quite interesting in that regard
all right jackie let's uh
put our bags to the side let's hang out
for a little bit
that's it
as you can see this is going to be the
new charging uh weight station
petrol stations might want to get some
sort of cafe or some tables to hang out
once we can obviously with you know the
situation here in singapore the pandemic
you know obviously we can't gather in
too many groups but as time permits i
think that'll make sense because we're
going to see a lot more of these
charging stations around here
and yeah it's going to make a big
difference so we got to about 60 on the
charge then all of a sudden there was a
charging error now i've noticed this
happening a couple times and this is
something that we've been seeing around
singapore and it's nothing to do really
with the bike
but the charging stations really aren't
ready for bikes yet i think from what i
understand so there are some errors with
it so i've got the sixty percent
which
will last me the rest of the day so i
have to return the bike but uh yeah this
should go to eighty percent then now
naturally shut off but i'm only going to
60 i've taken it in and out
not working yet so
i think we're just gonna get back on the
road and uh continue with this review
but
growing pains when you're into the
electric motorcycle world
so final thoughts on
the ava ssa 9 or novae plus you know
this is uh been a new experience for me
as i mentioned before i ride a triumph
speedmaster which is a much more classic
inspired bike of course it's a 2018
variant so it's uh newer in terms of its
technology
but to get on a bike like this it is um
it's exhilarating it's a lot of fun
but there is a learning curve as i
mentioned throughout this video in terms
of you know slow moving turns
how to you know basically just use your
right side of your body your throttle
your brakes and your left side is just
there for balance it's a little bit
discombobulating especially if you're
used to using you know learning clutch
control riding a motorcycle
but it's a comfortable bike to ride as i
mentioned before the speed the pickup is
phenomenal
i mean the power band on this there is
no dead spots it just goes up i really
like this bike and could i see myself
getting into an electric motorcycle and
the answer is yes i could i mean this is
a definitely uh an investment you know
here in singapore this comes in around
70 000 singapore dollars and you know
when you look on the website this is
around 20 22
000 euros so in singapore we have a high
increase of taxes on this bike so here
in singapore our taxes on motorcycles
and uh
just cars in general are very high and
that does make it a bit of a challenge
for a lot of people out there to
you know decide if they want to go
electric
because of the you know high up front
cost
or
just stick with a more traditional
motorcycle because with this price point
you're now competing with the uh higher
and harley davidsons here in singapore
ducati panigales street fighter v4s's
you know the triumph rocket
uh three so you're you're in that
ballpark you know obviously if you're
more into sustainable living and
eco-friendly and you want an electric
motorcycle
that cost might not be a deterrent for
you but having said that if you have the
means would i invest in it i would say
yes i would uh you're really going to
like the ride on this um
i mean energica is a smaller company but
they are back with a
really good partnership here in
singapore and they're really going to
support you on that and i know the guys
they're fantastic people and they are
here for the long haul and they believe
in this technology yeah i really like it
i really like this bike i think we're
ready to go zaki what do you think
yeah
yeah
zacky's hot sweaty we're sweating our
asses off out here right now anyway
those are my thoughts on the energica
ebay ss nove plus or ssa9 plus let me
know your thoughts in the comment
section below is this a bike that you're
looking to invest in is the price point
in singapore a little bit of a turn off
for you or
are you willing to take that step into
the future and go fully electric i would
love to hear from you guys on this
anyway with that stay safe on the roads
take care follow us on facebook
subscribe to us on youtube we'll chat
you in the next one
be safe on the roads guys